buenas tardes va a cambiar mucho desde
como los británicos pasan sus vacaciones
en europa hasta las importaciones y las
exportaciones y como las empresas pueden
estar preparadas es cierto no habrá
aduanas ni tarifas pero lo cierto es que
habrá burocracia y papeleo para las
importaciones a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 entra en vigor también un
acuerdo de libre comercio entre este
país y la unión europea que está
avaluado de más de 600 billones de
libras esterlinas un paso bien
importante también el primer ministro ha
dicho que el reino unido- recupera
entonces su independiente de
independencia política económica de su
presupuesto de sus leyes de sus
fronteras y de sus aguas además entra en
vigor un nuevo sistema migratorio la
libre circulación de ciudadanos europeos
se acaba si una persona del continente
quiere venir a trabajar o estudiar debe
ceñirse a un estricto sistema migratorio
de puntos debe mostrar suficiencia en el
idioma inglés
de mostrar calificaciones estudios y una
para la movilidad también cada país
europeo evaluará uno por uno del caso de
los británicos residentes en esos países
luisa el break sheet le da un gran
impulso a estos movimientos
independentistas y también a los
euroescépticos entonces cómo quedaría el
panorama después de que se lleve a cabo
esta salida del reino unido de la unión
europea
escocia es un país del reino unido- que
hace bastantes años estaba gritando por
tener su independencia lo que sucede en
este momento la primera ministra
escocesa nicola sturgeon ha dicho que
una de sus prioridades es convertir ese
camino de la independencia jurídico y
político posible en este momento dado la
gestión de nicola sturgeon sobre el
coronavirus de manera independencia y de
manera independiente en escocia hace
pensar que la independencia está ganando
cada vez más posibilidades